How the as as a message to people who
are watching this and trying to work
their way through a lot of young people
who were trying to navigate this
increasingly perilous minefield of
divisive politics.
In today's Day and age,
how do they know?
What are the heuristics they use?
What are the signposts they used to
understand,
am I on the right path?
Is is what I'm being taught or is what
I'm being attracted to politically
motivated from a sense of what's
actually best for the community that I'm
nominally caring for?
Well,
that requires.
It might say,
well that requires careful meditation
and prayer if you want it to be
traditional about it.
I would say you have to Orient.
You have to determine this is a process
of soul searching.
What are you oriented towards?
And the answer could easily be nothing.
Well,
this is why I produced the future
authoring program.
Like you've got to be oriented towards
something because otherwise you're
disoriented.
You just spin around in circles and then
you suffer and sort of people around
you.
It's not a good solution.
Orient itself towards something.
You have to figure out what it is,
what will work for you,
what goal would would justify the
suffering of your life.
Start trying to piece that together.
You're going to get better at it,
but it's a personal process and and you
should use your education to inform that
so you need a personal place to stand
because otherwise you're going to be
handed a place to stand on a plate and
it may be one that that makes you a
puppet of someone else's goals.
So I would say,
you know,
what are,
what are the processes?
Well,
I think what I've recommended to people
is clean up your room.
That's a good start.
Organize your local landscape.
Schedule your time,
start taking control of yourself.
See if you can stop saying things you
know to be lies.
That's not the same as telling the
truth.
You don't get to do that to begin with
because you're not good enough at it to
even attempt it in some sense,
but everyone can stop saying things they
know to be false hoods.
They can use their own damn definition
of falsehood,
right?
But in your definition,
importantly,
I think in your definition,
falsehood includes the higher level
moral truth,
living wrong.
You can say something that is literally
true,
but of course,
like you said earlier,
it's a black truth in the sense that at
a moral level you're saying something to
cause a social effect that is actually
negative.
Say,
stop saying things that violate your
conscience.
Instead of stop saying things you know
to be untrue,
because we run into the truth problem.
But I would say,
stop.
Here's another idea.
Stop saying and doing things that make
you feel weak is all you have to do is
pay attention to that.
Some things you do will make you feel
disintegrated.
It's a physiological sensation
disintegrated in week.
It's something that Carl Rogers
commented on and he thought about that
as part of,
oh,
now I can't remember the word.
Something like,
but that isn't the word he used,
but some things,
some things improve your integrity on.
Some things disintegrate.
You now the things that disintegrate
you,
you often do to impress other people or
because you're taking a shortcut or
you're escaping what you know to be your
moral obligation and your moral
obligation stems naturally from your
aims,
like once once you have aims,
you have moral obligations.
They come together because the moral
obligation is what you need to do in
order to obtain the Ame,
so and if you don't have a name,
well then you're aimless,
so that's not a solution.
So along with the aims come the moral
obligations.
Then when you violate the moral
obligations,
you'll have a sense of that violation.
It's like,
well,
you have to stop doing that or,
or that's something you could do.
You don't have to.
You don't have to do any of this,
but I would say that's where where
people should start.
You start small.
It's not small.
You think it's small.
I had a girl come up to me last night at
the end of my talk and this happens all
the time.
She said,
I started cleaning up my room last year
and it completely changed my life.
She said,
your room is an externalization of your
mind,
and that's right.
That's exactly true to the degree that
you're in your room,
the room is,
you know,
that isn't how people think,
but that's okay.
It doesn't matter if they think that
way.
That's how it is.
So straighten up what you can straighten
up and quit saying things that make you
feel weak and then then you'll know what
to do next.